[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zur Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es einen klassischen Kuchen
– aua!
Heute gibt es einen klassischen Kuchen, nämlich den
Butterkuchen.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit Mutterkuchen.
Komm, den musste ich jetzt sagen.
Okay. Gut, dass Murat nicht dabei ist.
Dem würden jetzt noch tausend Dinge einfallen,
die er euch erzählen möchte.
Ein Butterkuchen, das ist ein klassischer Blechkuchen
und eher ein Kuchen aus der norddeutschen Küche.
Aber den gibt es auch in Süddeutschland.
Und der wird traditionell natürlich mit Butter gemacht.
Daher auch der Name.
Den gibt es aber auch als Zuckerkuchen
und den bezeichnet man dann immer so,
wenn man Margarine statt Butter nimmt,
was so ein günstigeres Produkt,
eine günstige Alternative zum Butterprodukt ist.
Und dann gibt es noch Alternativen wie:
Man bestreut ihn mit Zimtzucker
oder man backt noch Obst rein, Kirschen zum Beispiel,
oder auch Cremes.
Wir machen es heute ganz klassisch,
ein ganz klassischer Hefeteig.
Der wird dann auf einem Blech gebacken,
mit Mandeln noch bestreut.
Und das Ganze wird ziemlich saftig und sehr lecker.
Und vor allem ist es ein Crowdfeeder.
Denn mit einem Blech könnt ihr wirklich
20 bis 30 Portionen direkt zaubern.
Und er ist wirklich superschnell gemacht.
Ich verwende dafür
einen Würfel Hefe,
– das sind 42 Gramm –
einen Esslöffel Wasser,
50 Gramm Zucker,
250 Gramm Milch,
ein Eigelb,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
500 Gramm Mehl,
einen halben Teelöffel Salz
und 100 Gramm weiche Butter.
Ich mache jetzt zuerst mal einen Vorteig.
Das heißt, ich verrühre die Hefe
mit dem Wasser
und dem Zucker
und lasse das Ganze dann wirklich kurz aufgehen.
So wird die Hefe einfach schon mal aktiviert
und später geht der Teig insgesamt besser auf.
Und
der wird auch ein bisschen feinporiger.
Also ihr könnt das machen, ihr müsst nicht.
Ihr könnt auch einfach direkt alle Zutaten verkneten.
Aber manchmal ist es doch schon ganz gut
mit ein bisschen Vorteig.
Also kurz verrühren,
bis sich die Hefe aufgelöst hat.
Jetzt könnt ihr auch gerne
zum Beispiel ein bisschen Mehl drauf streuen.
Und dann einfach an einem warmen Ort
oder hier in der Kenwood direkt
oder im Backofen bei etwa 34°C
einfach kurz aufgehen lassen.
Und es bilden sich dann meist so kleine Blubberbläschen
und dann geht es direkt mit dem Hefeteig weiter.
Sieht schon gut aus.
Ich habe es jetzt nur kurz aufgehen lassen
und habe in der Zwischenzeit
hier schon mal die Milch erwärmt.
Die war nämlich auch aus dem Kühlschrank
und da ist es einfach besser,
wenn die Milch ein bisschen warm ist,
aber nicht zu heiß.
Und jetzt könnt ihr einfach alle Zutaten
schön verkneten.
Salz und Fett immer zum Schluss dazu geben,
einfach, damit die Hefe schön aufgehen kann.
Hier das Hefegemisch rein.
Und da kann es jetzt einfach sein,
dass ihr je nachdem, welche Mehlsorte ihr habt,
bis zu 40 Gramm
– ja –
mehr oder weniger Mehl braucht.
Also ich habe jetzt hier ein Dinkelmehl 630.
Wenn ihr Weizenmehl habt,
ist der Teig etwas weicher.
Da könnt ihr ein bisschen mehr Mehl nehmen.
Da müsst ihr einfach immer mal gucken.
Also Hefeteig ist da echt so ein bisschen auch Gefühlssache.
Denn das Mehl nimmt einfach
unterschiedlich viel Feuchtigkeit auf.
Warme Milch.
Dann das Eigelb.
Und das Eiweiß könnt ihr schön aufbewahren,
entweder einfrieren oder Baiser daraus backen.
Ich lasse jetzt auch mal ein bisschen Mehl übrig.
Ich gebe hier jetzt noch das Vanilleextrakt dazu
für den besonders guten Geschmack.
Und jetzt hier noch Salz auf das Mehl.
Und den Teig kneten.
Und das Fett gebe ich jetzt, wie gesagt,
noch langsam mit dazu.
Mh. Anmachen sollte man sie schon.
Und ihr könnt hier auch direkt, wenn ihr eine Kenwood habt,
einfach schon mal Temperatur drauf geben.
Dann wird der Teig schon mal schön warm.
[Musik]
Und der Teig ist jetzt noch recht weich,
ist okay, aber ein bisschen Mehl gebe ich doch noch dazu.
Aber so ist er perfekt.
Er löst sich vom Schlüsselrand, bildet einen Kloß
und mehr Mehl brauche ich jetzt nicht dazu geben.
Also achtet einfach drauf, dass er schön weich ist.
Wie gesagt, das Mehl hier gebe ich jetzt nicht mehr dazu.
Das sind jetzt so 30 bis 40 Gramm.
Und jetzt lasse ich den Teig einfach
für etwa zehn Minuten kneten.
Das könnt ihr natürlich auch mit der Hand machen.
Das ist ein bisschen
– da seid ihr ein bisschen sportlich aktiv direkt.
Aber ich mache das jetzt einfach hier.
Und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt meinen Hefeteig.
Also, wenn ich den jetzt formen müsste,
wie zum Beispiel zu Buchteln oder Hefezopf
oder kleinen Teilchen,
dann hätte ich das Mehl schon noch dazu gegeben,
dass er einfach nicht so ganz weich ist.
Aber jetzt für den Butterkuchen
möchte ich ihn gerne ein bisschen weicher haben.
Also man sieht, der ist schön weich,
aber er klebt jetzt auch nicht so.
Das ist ein schöner, weicher Teig.
Den besprühe ich jetzt an der Oberfläche
mit Backtrennspray.
Ihr könnt ihn auch mit ein bisschen Butter bestreichen.
So trocknet die Oberfläche nicht aus.
Und dann einfach abgedeckt eine Stunde aufgehen lassen
oder auch gern in der Küchenmaschine
bei 34°C eine Dreiviertelstunde
oder im Dampfbackofen bei Gärstufe
für etwa eine halbe Stunde,
sodass er sich wirklich deutlich verdoppelt.
Und dann geht es gleich weiter.
Und die andere Butter,
– ich habe jetzt noch mal Butter,
denn es ist ja ein Butterkuchen –
die stelle ich jetzt kurz ins Gefrierfach.
Denn die muss gleich ganz kalt sein.
[Musik]
Der Hefeteig ist jetzt wunderbar aufgegangen.
Und ich habe jetzt hier meinen Backrahmen.
Das ist ja ein richtig super Backblechersatz.
Also ich habe hier ein Backblech, was gelocht ist.
Und normalerweise bekommt man ja im Backofen
diese Standard emaillierten Backbleche mitgeliefert
und backt darauf immer Blechkuchen.
Da finde ich es nur immer ganz unpraktisch,
dass man diese Rundungen hat.
Und dann hat man immer die Ecken
– die sind dann immer nicht schön eckig beim Blechkuchen.
Und hier habt ihr einfach den Vorteil:
Ihr habt hier das gelockte Blech, könnt schneller backen.
Und mit dem Backrahmen,
den ihr dann so ausziehen könnt,
habt ihr dann auch hier an den vier Seiten
einfach schöne Ecken und alles ist gleichmäßig gerade.
Also den Hefeteig nehme ich jetzt raus.
Der kommt hier rein.
Dann gerne die Hände leicht fetten.
Die meisten rollen es aus.
Aber ich finde, das kann man einfach
hier mit den Händen richtig schön machen.
Da muss man nämlich kein Mehl benutzen.
[Musik]
Also schön gleichmäßig verteilen.
Und jetzt ist ganz wichtig:
Den Teig noch mal aufgehen lassen,
damit der Kuchen wirklich schön locker wird.
Und danach kommt noch mal Butter ran.
[Musik]
Der Hefeteig ist jetzt wunderbar aufgegangen.
Jetzt habe ich hier den Butterblock.
Das sind 150 Gramm, also einfach noch der Rest.
Die 100 habe ich ja im Teig.
Man muss echt dazu sagen,
dass in so einem Butterkuchen nicht mehr Butter drin ist
als in so einem ganz normalen Rührkuchen.
Denn, wenn ich so einen Gugelhupf mache
mit 250 Gramm Butter,
verteilt der sich auch auf eine Gugelhupfform.
Und ich finde, der Name erweckt schon den Eindruck,
als hätte man hier
nur noch Butter drin.
Aber es ist echt nicht so.
Also gar nicht viel mehr als in so einem Standardkuchen.
Und die Butter hatte ich eingefroren,
damit ich jetzt schöne Würfelchen schneiden kann.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich jetzt
etwas Backtrennspray
und drücke jetzt hier Vertiefungen rein.
Zack! Zack!
[Musik]
Und dann kommt immer so ein Würfelchen davon rein.
Und jetzt mit Zucker bestreuen.
>> SARAH: Tut mir leid, Sally.
Ich möchte den Kuchen nicht probieren.
>> SALLY: Der Kuchen gehört so!
In Dänemark, da gibt es...
>> JOSH: Kann man machen.
>> SALLY: Aber jetzt guckt einmal.
Im Hefeteig habe ich auch nicht viel Zucker,
nur 50 Gramm. Ja?
Und hier obendrauf, das waren jetzt
– wie viel war denn das?
>> AYLIN: 100.
>> SALLY: 100.
100 und 50.
Das heißt, der hat immer noch weniger Zucker
als ein normaler Marmorkuchen.
Auch wenn es nicht so aussieht,
100 Gramm weniger Zucker.
>> JOSH: Überzeugt.
>> SALLY: Überzeugt?
>> SALLY: Und jetzt noch gestiftete Mandeln.
[Musik]
Also ich finde, der Name, der schreckt schon ab,
Butterkuchen.
Aber, wie gesagt, weniger Zucker als ein Marmorkuchen,
gleich viel Fett wie ein Marmorkuchen.
Von daher finde ich das gar nicht so schlimm.
Wenn man möchte, kann man jetzt hier
noch Kirschen mit drauf geben oder Mandarinen zum Beispiel
oder auch einen Pudding mit einbacken.
Ich mache das jetzt heute ganz klassisch.
Den Ofen habe ich jetzt bereits vorgeheizt.
Und jetzt kommt der Kuchen in den Backofen,
wird gebacken und danach wird probiert.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist jetzt gebacken
und auch schon ein bisschen abgekühlt.
Jetzt kann ich ihn hier rauslösen.
Ich bin echt gespannt drauf, wie er schmeckt.
Und der Zucker an der Oberfläche,
der karamellisiert ja so ein bisschen.
Daher...
Ach, das ist bestimmt ein leckerer Kuchen.
La, la, la, la, la, la.
Dann einfach runterziehen.
Und die Backfolie lösen.
Perfekt!
Dann habe ich hier diesen Kucheneinteiler.
Und der hat zum einen 30 und 20 Stücke,
also entweder ein bisschen kleiner oder größer.
Ich mache jetzt 30,
kann es jetzt hier drauf legen,
leicht andrücken.
Also der schneidet es nicht durch,
der teilt es nur ein.
Und dann kann ich ihn zuschneiden
und habe schöne, gleichmäßig große Stücke.
[Musik]
Lieber Murat, du darfst probieren.
>> MURAT: So. Hallo! Ich lebe noch.
Ich weiß, ihr habt mich schon lang nicht mehr gesehen.
>> SALLY: Ja,
>> MURAT: Das liegt daran, dass ich in Mannheim
ein Café betreibe.
Und...
>> SALLY: Murats Stammtisch jeden Tag.
>> MURAT: Ich mache meinen Stammtisch.
Jeden Tag bin ich in Mannheim momentan.
>> SALLY: Im Q 6 Q 7 im 1. OG.
>> MURAT: Ja, von 10 bis 15 Uhr.
Ja.
Darf ich was sagen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Oder muss ich es dann rausschneiden?
>> SALLY: Du darfst was sagen.
>> MURAT: Um 15 Uhr gehe ich, weil...
[Zensurton]
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> SALLY: Das schneiden wir raus natürlich.
>> MURAT: Das war ein Spaß! Mein Gott!
Nein, das schneiden wir nicht raus.
Nein, das war nur ein Spaß.
Es war lustig.
Es war schön.
Kann ich einfach den Kuchen probieren?
>> SALLY: Kannst du einfach Kuchen probieren?
>> MURAT: Ja, ich probiere einfach den Kuchen.
Oh, oh!
Okay. Ich probiere den Kuchen jetzt, ja?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also nicht alle. Ich habe nur so viele drauf,
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: weil es schön aussieht.
Was ist das?
>> MURAT: Sieht völlig unspektakulär aus, der Kuchen,
aber richtig genial!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Du hast noch nicht mal geschluckt.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und?
>> MURAT: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Weißt du, was das ist?
>> MURAT: Mhm.
Mandeln.
>> SALLY: Ein Butterkuchen.
>> MURAT: Echt?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Voll lecker!
Mh.
Ist euch eigentlich aufgefallen, dass ich abgenommen habe?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Gell?
>> MURAT: Die letzten – Ding...
Cool.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Seitdem der Shop in Mannheim offen hat.
>> MURAT: Aber ehrlich, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Guckt mal. Ihr seht mich ja immer weniger.
>> SALLY: Erst schlucken, dann sprechen.
>> MURAT: Und ja, ich muss dann nicht mehr
probieren
und habe 10 Kilo abgenommen. Wahnsinn, oder?
So einfach geht das.
Hammer!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Erinnert dich Butterkuchen
auch an Mutterkuchen?
>> MURAT: Nein. Oh!
Und meine Frau ist lustiger geworden in letzter Zeit.
Ja.
Aber richtig cool! Ohne Spaß.
Ganz toll. Ganz einfach, denke ich, oder?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Hm.
>> SALLY: Mh.
[Backofen-Signalton]
Pst!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Boah!
>> SALLY: Jetzt, wo du in Mannheim bist,
>> MURAT: Ja?
>> SALLY: muss ich ja die Rolle übernehmen
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: und kann jetzt aus mir rauskommen.
Nein, ich bin nicht schwanger!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Schmeckt super!
Es schmeckt echt toll. Wirklich.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich finde es auch.
>> MURAT: Ich kann sogar die Wahrheit sagen.
>> SALLY: Krass!
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Echt mal gut. So ein schöner Sonntagsklassiker.
Also wirklich ein Kuchen,
>> MURAT: Richtig cool!
>> SALLY: den man einfach mal superschön vorbereiten kann.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und supersaftig.
Und ich habe vorhin schon gesagt:
Nur, weil er Butterkuchen heißt,
heißt das nicht, dass da jetzt mehr Butter drin ist
als in so einem Marmorkuchen.
Aber man schmeckt die Butter einfach schön raus, finde ich.
>> MURAT: Ich finde, der schmeckt so ähnlich
wie der Streuselkuchen.
Kennst du den? Streuseltalerkuchen.
Oder wie heißt das? So. Genau.
>> SALLY: Oh, Streuseltaler! Leckerschmecker!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Also probiert den Kuchen gerne aus.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Falls ihr kein ganzes Blech backen wollt,
könnt ihr natürlich auch ein halbes Blech backen.
Ihr könnt ja dann einfach
den Backrahmen zusammenschieben.
Da stehen ja die Maße drauf.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und in meiner App könnt ihr euch
einfach das Rezept umrechnen lassen.
Also der hier hat jetzt 32 mal 37 cm, Blechgröße.
Und dann kann man auch ein halbes Blech backen.
Und das passt dann, wie gesagt, auch perfekt.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und der Kuchen, der ist wirklich
mehrere Tage saftig und haltbar
und sehr lecker.
>> MURAT: Ihr könnte mich übrigens auf Instagram
– wenn ich schon dabei bin, schon mal wieder dabei:
Ihr könnt mich auf Instagram abonnieren.
Ich heiße da der_murat.
>> SALLY: Unterstrich.
>> MURAT: Ja, Unterstrich.
>> SALLY: Zweimal.
>> MURAT: Also der_murat_.
>> SALLY: Ja. Bitte folgt ihm.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Er ist wirklich witzig.
>> MURAT: Ich mache jetzt mein eigenes Ding.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> SALLY: Noch mal.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> MURAT & SALLY & JOSH & SARAH: Oh!
>> MURAT: Mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Also,
>> MURAT: Okay, tschüss! Macht's gut!
>> SALLY: wie gesagt, das Rezept gibt es auf sallys-blog.de
oder in der App.
Tschüss!
Warte. Ich komme.
>> MURAT: Nein!
>> SALLY: Doch.
[Musik]